ESLint is an indispensable code
quality tool when you're writing
any type of JavaScript,
especially ES6. You may have
used JSHint or JSLint in the
past. However, it seems to be
that most of the community has
moved over to ESLint,
specifically because they have
support for all of the new ES6
features. Now what is ESLint?
ESLint essentially, it hurts
your feelings. It looks at your
code and tells you what exactly
is wrong with it. At first
it seems a little bit
overwhelming because it tells
you everything is wrong with
your code, but it's all a matter
of, A, getting it configured
properly for your coding style,
and B, actually understanding
why are these errors happening.
In the long run, it's going to
make you a much better developer.
Let's take a look right here.
I've just got some of my code
right here and I popped it into
the ESLint. It just starts
yelling at you for all the
things that you have done wrong,
like let's see, on the first one,
space after keyword was removed.
Here we go. Extra space after
the keyword conditions was using,
right here, it was a little
space. It will do little
things like that, as well as
catch things for you where maybe
you used a variable name twice,
or maybe you have an unused
variable name, or maybe you use
the wrong var, let, or const.
All kinds of different stuff
where this is going to come back
and bite you, and ESLint is
going to catch them before they
actually cause an issue. I'm
going to go through setting it
up, getting it installed, and
then I'm going to show you how
do you configure it and what is
your process for actually
understanding how it works.
In my experience, the first time
someone uses it takes maybe an
hour or two to get it really
where they like it, but you're
going to be writing better code
and you're going to earn that
time back after no time.
There's a few things we need to
in order to get started. First
of all, you need nodejs and npm
installed. Chances are, most of
you already have this installed.
If you don't know, head on over
to your terminal and type node-v,
and it'll tell you what version
of node you have. Make sure
you have at least version four
or up, and npm-v make sure you
have at least version three or
up, and that means you're in
good shape. If you have an
old version or you get an error,
like node is not a command, go
to nodejs.org and download the
latest version. It will just
give you the thing or you click
next, next, next, and get that
installed. Once you have
that installed, we need to
install ESLint. The way that
ESLint is going to work is we're
going to type ESLint, and we're
going to lint a file called
badcode.js. When you run that
it's going to give us either an
error or actually what problems
are with our code. To install
that, you type npminstall-g.
What -g is going to do is
install globally on your machine,
so I have that ESLint command.
Then you type ESLint and hit
enter. I'm not going to do that,
because I already have it. A
lot of people on OSX, on a Mac,
they're going to get a problem
with permissions. You type sudo
npm install, or figure out
actually how to get npm install
working just properly. If you
have that properly installed,
you should be able to type
ESLint--version and it should
tell you that you have at least
version two or up, but do
yourself a favor and jut
download the latest version of
ESLint. Now, we're going to
be working from the command line.
I'm going to show you how to
integrate it into your text
editor in just a bit, but let's
get it up and running. How do
you actually get it to work?
You're not going to paste it
into this little box every
single time you want to check
your code quality. Ideally
what's going to happen is we're
going to have something that
runs on our command line,
something that runs in our
editor, or something that runs
on a Git hook before you commit
your actual code. Let's start
via the command line. You just
type ESLint and type badcode.
That's a file that I've included
in this folder here. What that's
going to do is it's going to
scan our file and tell us what
is actually wrong with it. First
of all, it seems like there's a
problem parsing this actual, and
this is a pretty common thing.
It's telling me it's on line 1
of column 38. If you look here
at line one, column 38, that's
actually where the error is. By
default ESLint doesn't know
about arrow functions, and this
is where the settings for ESLint
actually start to come in handy.
Now the ESLint settings, you can
do them globally on your
computer and I'll show that in a
second. Or you can do it project
by project. A lot of people
prefer to do it project by
project because there's
different coding styles
depending on which project or
team you are working with.
We are going to go ahead and
create what's called an eslintrc
file in the folder right here,
and that's going to hold all of
our actual settings. I'm
going to say touch.eslintrc.
That will have created a new
file called .eslintrc. Sometimes
some computers hide files that
start with dot, so you might not
immediately see it in your
Finder. However, if you go to
your editor and open that folder
you should see a .eslintrc file.
Open that up, now it's going to
be empty. Inside of this
eslintrc file we are going to
write json, which is full of all
of our settings. To write json,
you open up an object and we now
need to specify a whole bunch of
options that we need. What
are the possible options? Well,
ESLint is full of options, and
it can be a little bit
overwhelming. Look at right
here. First of all we have an
environments. Where are you
actually writing your JavaScript?
Are you writing it for Node? Are
you writing it for your browser?
Are you writing amd, Mocha,
Jasmine, PhantomJS, QUnit, all
the way? You see that we are
writing ES6 for the browser. We
might also want to write it for
Node. There's also all these
different rules. This is all the
possible rules that you can have.
We'll look at a shortcut way,
because there's no way you have
time to make a decision about
every single one of these rules.
First of all, what we want to do
is say environment. We're
writing json here, you must use
double quotes. Nth, and here we
set all the environments that we
would like to write our code in.
We're going to say ES6 is an
environment we would like to
write our code in. That is true.
Also you may want to put the
browser, since we are writing in
the browser. If you are writing
in Node then that would also be
handy to set to true. And
finally, if you're ever writing
some jQuery it's helpful to put
jQuery in there because
otherwise it's going to complain
about certain things like the
dollar sign not being defined
when it clearly is. I'm going
to keep it just at ES6 and
browser. However, you can always
go to the ESLint, go to user
guide, and go on rules, and
you'll be able to see all the
possible rules, as well as if
you go to configuring ESLint.
You're going to see a list of
all of the possible environments.
Take a look here, specifying
environments, browser, Node,
CommonJS, ES6, worker, AMD. The
ones that we all looked about.
You can take a look at those.
Now, I've set the environment
ES6 to be true, and now we
should be able to run ESLint
badcode. It doesn't tell us
anything. Why is that? Because
by default ESLint doesn't have
any rules enabled. You have to
turn on all the rules.
Rather than you having to go to
user guide, rules and just wade
through all of these possible
rules, what happens is that
there are handy presets out
there for other people that have
put together. There's one is
the ESLint recommended. The way
that you pick up someone else's
preset is you say extends and
you say ESLint recommended. Give
that a save. Now if we go
back to our terminal and rerun
that, there we go. Now it's
going to tell us, reject is
define but never used,
unexpected console, and
unexpected console. If we go
back to our badcode here, you'll
see on line seven we pass the
reject, but we actually never
use it because we only use
resolve. I know, "Well, what's
the point in passing that? It
wasn't necessary for me," so I'm
going to remove it, save it,
rerun ESLint. Now we only
have two errors. Now, I've got
the same error happening on line
17 and line 21. Right here I'm
using console.log and on line 29,
I'm also using console.log.
It's telling me I shouldn't be
using console but I'm saying, "
It's fine that I'm using console,
I know what I'm doing. I'll make
sure that it take them out, or
maybe I'll have another ESLint
that that role will be set on
development and not in
production." But if I want
to turn that off, what I do is I
go back to my eslintrc file. I
make a rules here. Then we go
ahead and set every single rule
how we want it. How do you
actually work with these rules?
The rule is this one, no console.
What I usually do is I'll go
here and say, there we go, no
console. Click through to it,
and spend some time reading why
this rule. Don't just turn
it off immediately because it's
annoying and you think you're
right. Maybe just spend some
time and say, "Maybe I shouldn't
be using this rule, or maybe I
shouldn't be writing my code in
this way. Why is this possibly
bad?" Read through why they
think that maybe this rule
should be turned on. It looks at
some examples as to what you
shouldn't be using, and then
finally there is when not to use
it. How do you turn it off if
you don't like it? There's a
couple ways you can turn it off.
At the very high level there's
three stages of rules. They can
be off, they can be warning, or
they can be error. Sometimes I
like to turn things on just to
warning, so I know that that
possibly shouldn't be there.
However, an error will go red.
What we do is you take your rule
here, no console, and we set it
to either off, warn, or error.
Or what I like to do is zero is
off, one is warn, and two is the
actual error. There's also the
ability to pass options here.
We'll look at that in just a
second, but that's very basic.
Let's say I want to turn it off
entirely. I'm going to say rules,
no console. What's that's doing
is it's taking all the rules
from the ESLint recommended, and
then we're taking the no console
and just applying our own. It's
like CSS, where you have a base
framework here and then you
overwrite your own specific ones.
Now if we go back and rerun
ESLint you'll see that we get no
actual errors here, because
according to recommended and our
one rule here, we have totally
made things up. However, if
I look at this code right here,
you'll know that there are a
whole bunch of things that are
bugging me here. First of all,
what is this space here? Second
of all, I have the spacing
that's inconsistent with that, I
have no space here where there
should be one there. It
should be catching more
stylistic errors that I actually
have, as well as things like why
am I using var, let, and const
all over the place, when I
shouldn't be using var. Let
tweets here is not being
reassigned, so it shouldn't be a
let, it shouldn't be a const.
There's all kinds of stuff, so
in the next video what I'm going
to do is look at the Airbnb
default, which is a little bit
more strict but will allow you
to write much better code.